a general approach which will guarantee
the protection of more than 4 million
workers from exposure to carcinogens or
mutagens in the workplace has now been
reached this is particularly important
given that cancer the first cause of
work-related deaths in the EU the
proposed directive seeks to introduce
stricter limits on exposure values and
skin notations for five carcinogenesis
when the skin notations independently of
limit values for two more carcinogens
covering 7 carcinogens in total this
year we have a fewer country specific
recommendations and recommendations
place a strong emphasis on both matter
economic and social issues and then on
the posting of burgers on this dossier
we are unfortunately not there yet the
revision of the directives remains a
priority file for us we want the same
rules on remuneration to apply to the
same work at the same location I am
confident that under the Estonian
presidency we can bring this to a good
end
but discussions go on in today's
discussion there was a broad consensus
on the content of the social values and
principles that we share in Europe the
palette of social rights is not only
about protecting but also about
empowering people about supporting
people thereby ensuring that Union as a
whole remains competitive the pillar is
our chance to reconnect the EU with its
citizens
we all agreed together to improve
employment and social conditions but we
have also agreed that the process should
take into account that we have different
starting points different national
circumstances and that we will move at
different speeds